so i have a very important topic today i
mean this is like probably
something that everyone needs to know
about as their foundational knowledge in
nutrition okay and it relates to
genetics
so many people think that well you know
i just have bad genes
and there's nothing i can do about it we
just have to cope with it but first of
all you can control your genes through
what's called epigenetics i have a lot
of information on that
and that has to do with just lifestyle
changes right because the genes can turn
on and off based on what happens in your
environment but what i want to talk
about
is
the deeper cause of genetic
malformations
now this talk is inspired by this
amazing book that i got which was
actually very expensive 250
soil grass and cancer okay
the link between human and animal health
and the mineral balance in the soil
fascinating and i'm on chapter 16 and
it's talking about the diet of the
mother and malformation of the child so
i want to read a couple quotes right
here
almost all malformations observed in man
have been reproduced in laboratory
experiments with rats by altering the
mother's diet during
pregnancy a diet deficient in folic acid
produces virtually all known types of
abnormalities in the hearts arteries and
veins of baby
rats so a lot of these malformations can
be reproduced if you create a deficiency
in the diet so i have a question
when do you think the most important
time
to eat healthy would be
if your answer was when you're pregnant
you are correct because
the fetus the growing baby that is
developing
is
completely dependent on the nutrients of
the mother and if there's just one thing
missing it can create a devastating
chain reaction effect
in their future existence and i'm
talking about behavior
talking about intelligence i'm talking
about structure
okay um
like if someone is born with flat feet
scoliosis hunchback whatever
or dental malformations or some
malformation in the shape of their face
it's all dependent on the nutrients the
nutrients especially trace minerals
are essential for enzymes and proteins
to work and i'm not just talking about
metabolism and building a body but i'm
also talking about the repair enzymes
within your dna so your genes are
basically blueprints right to allow
certain cellular machinery to take that
information and then build healthy
tissue you have actually
two different sets of
proofreading machines that actually go
through the dna at a very fast rate and
they're scanning your dna which are the
blueprints for errors okay and then
there's at least five
different repair
proteins or enzymes that we know about
there could be more
that are in a constant repair action to
repair
any errors that occurred in this code
and all of these repair enzymes are
dependent on
micronutrients like
folate
like zinc
cobalt that makes b12
copper which is another trace mineral
that makes vitamin c
iron and if i didn't mention iodine i'll
mention it again iodine it's a huge
connection between iodine and
a child's intelligence and then we have
manganese there's great information on
the relationship between a manganese
deficiency and a structural problem that
could develop in a body then you also
have calcium calcium deficiency which
could come from a vitamin d deficiency
and then we have selenium which helps
make up vitamin e and so all these
nutrients are just so vital
to
be available when someone is pregnant as
well as when they're breastfeeding and
now of course if they're not
breastfeeding of course they're probably
put on formula which i don't even want
to get into that topic at this point but
unfortunately the
formulas are soy based and i mean they
actually talk about the worst ingredient
to give a child
especially when they're developing is
soy because of its estrogen effect i
mean if you even think about another
cause of
genetic alteration
you have um toxins right you have what's
called endocrine disruptors okay well
guess what is included in the definition
of an endocrine disruptor any chemical
or toxin that mimics
estrogen okay
and we know that certain things in our
environment like even soy can increase
estrogen and you shouldn't be giving
someone that early in life
so much estrogen but that's a whole
different topic basically in this video
i want to talk about just the
relationship between micronutrients and
your genes and the importance of getting
these micronutrients in your diet
especially at an early age now there's
some other additional information i want
to share with you in fact i'm going to
read it off right now
in this study
entitled micronutrients and genomic
stability and basically this is about
stabilizing your genes with
micronutrients a new paradigm for
recommending dietary allowances the rdas
diet as a key factor in determining
genomic stability is more important than
previously imagined because we now know
it impacts on all relevant pathways
namely exposure to dietary carcinogens
activation detoxification of carcinogens
dna repair dna synthesis
so in other words we have not given
these macronutrients enough emphasis
on their importance
in
making sure that our genes are stable so
you have certain genetic defects that
you might be born with right
but you also have
genetic mutations
and genetic mutations
can occur
this life
so a genetic mutation is a as a change
in your code that can occur from either
being exposed to a toxin this life or
having some micronutrient deficiency
this life
in fact there's data which i'm going to
put all this research down below
that demonstrates
nutritional deficiencies
can mimic
radiation damage to your dna that's
mind-blowing so deficiencies in folate
b12 vitamin c
iron especially zinc okay
iodine manganese selenium
if you're deficient in those that
deficiency can mimic
actual damage of your dna now you
wouldn't actually think of a missing
element causing damage because it's
missing and you don't really look for
things that are missing you might think
more of like radiation toxicity things
like that
but micronutrient deficiency is a very
important thing so getting back to this
book for a second
he's going into deficiencies of copper
in the soil
can cause various problems
in the animals that eat the grass and
they've actually taken like
lambs and they've moved them into
different pastures with certain
nutrients present
and these certain problems disappear
so this leads me to our actual food you
know if your food is grown on soils that
are missing certain nutrients
it could have devastating effects the
problem now is farmers use three
minerals npk okay n nitrogen p
phosphorus and k potassium
but what about all the other 90 plus
minerals or trace minerals or elements
that you need in the soil that is an
area that i'm very interested in that's
an area that i'm doing research now on a
farm where i'm actually doing all sorts
of experiments in fact recently i've
just done an experiment spraying all of
our grass
with
a very unique type of
ocean water without so much of the
sodium chloride because that can be
toxic to the grass so we're doing
experiments i will be doing a video on
this but apparently it can really
fortify the soil with all the
micronutrients and limit the fungal
infections to the plants
and it can actually greatly enhance
the health of an animal which then
enhances the health of
humans that eat the animals and i'm also
doing experiments in my greenhouse which
i'll share with you as well
on using
hydroponic type solutions now
here's the problem that i have with
hydroponic and i'm doing the study right
now and i'll share the results
when i'm done
now in one hydroponic unit i'm using
just the normal mineral solution that
they give you which is actually only
like 15 minerals okay and the other one
i'm using
all 94 minerals and so i'm going to do
testing and i'll share the results with
you but it's is fascinating to me that
we're not emphasizing the foundation
which our food grows on and how that can
affect our bodies i mean just take for
example um
a tomato from italy if you've never
tasted a tomato from italy
you need to do it it's incredible and so
like why
do these tomatoes from italy taste so
darn good is it the seed
no it's in the soil what is so unique in
the soil well they have a lot of soils
that have been around volcanoes as in
volcano ash or minerals that provide the
necessary
elements for these plants to thrive on
and so of course in my greenhouse i use
volcanic minerals as one of the
fertilizers which i will be starting a
whole new youtube channel on that very
soon so the minerals in the soil supply
the plants what they need the nutrients
in our body provide us with stable
genes that then we can grow healthy
bodies on so again i want to emphasize
the importance of making sure
that
someone who's pregnant gets the right
nutrition not some synthetic prenatal
but the actual diet eating food
very nutrient dense
as well as fortifying
the woman who's breastfeeding as well
that's very very important and hopefully
she will breastfeed because
the formulas out there are just so
deficient in nutrients i mean they
actually talk about like folic acid
being so important
in preventing birth defects but what
about all the other micronutrients and
also in the right form something missing
in the diet can leave the child with
permanent
problems in their future health and that
leads me to the next question what is
the diet
of a child nowadays well unfortunately
it's ultra processed food it's not just
junk food it's
really bad junk food in fact
67
of their calories are ultra processed
junk food now does this have an effect
on the child well what do you think
in a major way all right next question
and please
type this in the comments below because
i want to read this at what age did you
start eating
healthy
for me it was 28 years old yeah 28 years
old i'm actually 35 now so that's it's
been some years and i'm being very
sarcastic because i'm in my 50s now but
the point is that hopefully it's sooner
than later for some of you watching you
haven't started eating healthy yet
so i just want to encourage you to do
that and also encourage any
female who is pregnant to start eating
healthy immediately and also get the
right micronutrients and i'm not bias of
my micronutrients but i will do a plug
for my trace minerals because trace
minerals are involved in so many
different biochemical pathways and it's
such a an easy thing to provide trace
minerals in a
blended form versus to try to take
individual trace minerals one by one
not being sure if you're getting the
right balance and i think out of all the
vitamins and minerals trace minerals are
kind of like the most
ignored because i think people don't
understand what they do and they don't
understand that our food nowadays is
deficient in micronutrients unless
they're consuming nutrient-dense foods
and then you have a woman who's pregnant
they go to the doctor and the doctor
monitors
the growth of this developing baby right
but they're not looking at the diet
they're not measuring any deficiencies
they're unfortunately just not trained
in nutrition so this video is very very
very important in increasing your
awareness
on
healthy eating and i think the next
video for you to watch is what to eat
that's nutrient dense so i put it up
right here check it out